well in between takes I think you
mentioned a book about editing that was
interesting in the blink of an eye it's
one of the required reading books at the
American Film Institute that's written
by Walter Murch who was a very famous
editor and he has this theory that we
don't blink randomly but we kind of
blink when we digest a chunk of
information in our head you know and
that you should pay attention to your
blinking rhythm when you are watching
your edit and see if that kind of goes
along with the the exclamation marks and
the commas and all that in your movie
and that you can watch an audience watch
your movie and look at their blinking
rhythm and you know whether your story
is well told or not depending on whether
that syncs up with your story or not I
think that's even a theory in dating
that people whose blinking doesn't sync
up that they don't match because their
brains work differently and processed
differently and I think maybe you know
that from your own life if you were
telling a story to someone and that
person blinks in the wrong moment
subconsciously you know that that person
is not really listening to your story
and you know that something's off you
know even if you can't put your finger
on it and I think Walter Murch and that
book kind of really focuses in on that
and explains that right I mean just a
side note what I wear contacts sometimes
I will be glued it's because they're dry
but other than that that definitely
makes sense like if you see someone
maybe look up and I know there's
different theories on where someone
looks when they're telling you something
as to whether that's true or not but
have you watched people watch a cut of
your film and been conscious of their
eyes oh yeah because I can for some
reason I can't not watch my own movie if
it's a screening that I'll do a Q&A
after I can't because other people just
go get a drink and come back for the Q&A
into the Q&A I always have the feeling I
have to watch the movie with that
audience to have get a feeling for their
experience of it so that I know we're
talking about the same movie because
every audience weirdly I haven't figured
why has a different experience watching
the exact same movie and you can tell
that they are laughing at different
moments you can tell that they're in in
suspense in different moments I don't
know why that is there's some high group
dynamic going on so I mean it's really
interesting to to see a movie with that
audience and then I'm watching their
reactions a lot in the dark you know
like a creep without them knowing and
and sometimes I see them blink at the
wrong moments and I'm like oh man I wish
I had known that earlier I'm losing them
in that in that moment or that in that
it's the same as if there was a joke in
there and the audience doesn't laugh
thank you God I did the joke not work or
did you lose them somewhere along the
line completely so that they didn't even
realize that there was a joke you know
so it's it's a terrifying experience
watching your movie with an audience for
sure but the blinking the blinking helps
I think it depends to what type of an
audience if you're watching it with
people who are within the industry let's
say they're journalists they see three
movies a week I think maybe there's a
desensitization a little bit whereas if
you watched with people that they work
nine to five jobs and then that's their
entertainment for the Friday night
they're gonna be giddy and having fun if
it's a comedy you know or if they want
to be scared they're gonna be maybe more
high you know because they want to feel
something
sure but of course ideally that the the
hope would be that you can penetrate
that cynicism that you've created a
story that is interesting enough and
surprising enough and strong enough
emotionally that even the guy that
watches three movies a day because it's
his job any kind of hates having to
watch another one if you can get that
guy to forget that that's his draw for
an hour and a half you know and can send
him on that journey that he didn't even
want to go on to I think then you have a
strong movie I don't know if I've made
that movie yet but I would I know that
that's kind of the goal but it's not
audience dependent but it's so strong
narrative Lee that it would grab anyone
that you would have to be deaf dumb and
blind to not be affected by right now
why now i sat next to journalists who
have literally jumped out of their chair
at a certain point so that not to say
and that was my bad that there
disaffected but I think in some cases
we've just seen so much that you know it
is they can predict the narrative and if
it turns and all that kind of stuff
right but with this book do you remember
reading it
do you remember and what besides the the
rhythm to me that's just fascinating now
I'm gonna be very conscious of that even
in just daily life but then you're
screwed because I was the same after
reading that book I was on now I'm gonna
have to pay attention when to blink and
suddenly you're blinking rhythm isn't
natural anymore and you've lost already
so you got to get that out of your head
again as quickly as possible and then
when you're editing your movie that's
true yeah it's that's where sometimes
ignorance ignorance is bliss because if
you if you know too much about like
micro expressions and things like that
then you're kind of like hmm yeah
they're not being sincere but when you
went to AFI that was required reading
and you remember how different it was
for you after you finish the book how
you approached being in the editing room
and watching even other students see a
rough cut of your films I think it just
blends and you're bombarded with so much
stuff because there were 50 books on
that required reading list so there's
all this stuff that I think you don't
you don't concentrate on one particular
thing you've learned and then you apply
it right there
but it's this this library of vague
stuff that will kind of rear its head
the details will rear their heads
hopefully when they are required and
some of the time you don't even know it
but you have a feeling for oh I remember
something about that and I think with
that it was like that I can't remember
specifically sitting in the editing room
and going like let me look at my editor
and count how often she blinks to see
that we're on the same page and we're
making the same movie you know it's just
something kind of vaguely remember
you